- I put on my orange suit
because somebody's about to walk out here
who is a cultural icon.
But fun fact, do you know
that she actually worked
as a bricklayer and a
mortuary cosmetologist?
I gotta know what happened.
Whoopi Goldberg, everybody!
(audience applauding)
So happy to see you.
- And you.
Hey, hi.
(audience applauding)
- I know, right?
Oh my God, I'm so happy to see you.
- Hello.
- Did you put makeup on dead people?
- Yeah, oh my God, yeah.
I put stuff on and you put stuff on
and make sure eyes don't pop open.
- Did you have to seal them shut?
- Yeah, in the old days, yeah.
And that's what they did.
You know, they...
- Ironically, something
that is going around,
I can't even turn on
Instagram or any outlet,
I feel like, without
hearing about Sister Act 3.
Talk about...
(audience applauding)
Like, everybody wants it to happen.
- Yeah.
- Everybody's asking you, cast,
like, Kiki Palmer, obviously.
- Everybody wants to be in it.
We just got the script
(Drew squeals excitedly)
on Friday.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, that's major!
- I'm very, very, very pleased.
Whatever's wrong, we can fix.
And I just want them to give us a go date.
So you should let me know if you are in.
- I will. Are you kidding me?
- No.
- With bells on.
- Why not? Why not?
- Anything, are you kidding?
- No, let's have some fun.
Remember that?
Remember having fun?
- I do remember having fun.
- Let's have some fun.
- I feel like everyone
you mention this to,
they're just immediately on board.
You've built, this will be the third.
- Yeah.
- The holy trinity of Sister Act 3.
- Well, it's, listen,
you can't go wrong with 15 singing nuns.
(audience laughing)
You just, you can't, you know.
And there's no reason why-
I don't know how many of you remember this
but when I was a kid, there
was a show called Batman.
- Yes, Adam West.
- Adam West, the fabulous late Adam West.
- Yes.
- And they would be walking
up the side of the building
and some major star would open
a window and say something.
I feel like we can incorporate that.
Somebody's coming out of the confessional
(audience laughing)
maybe dressed as a priest or as a nun.
(audience applauding)
You know, anything, anything is possible.
- Did you see, I was
watching in real time,
my television was on and I had
it on Jennifer Hudson's show.
- [Whoopi] Yes, I did.
- And she came out on Halloween.
- [Whoopi] Yes.
- As you and sang that song.
- [Whoopi] And sang that song.
I made everybody realize,
oh, she should be a singer.
(audience laughing)
It's like, no, no, no.
She's brilliant, but...
- Well, and you're both EGOTs.
- She's fabulous.
- Both of you are EGOTs.
- Yes. Yes.
(audience applauding)
- Now, we were looking at your
IMDB, your movie credit list.
There's over 200
- Oh.
Oh.
- credits on there.
Is there anything in that
200 that you haven't done
and you're dying to do?
A remake, some character
you've never gotten to play?
Anything that is like an
itch you haven't scratched?
- Yes, there's only one.
- What?
- I really want to play a monster
(audience laughing)
because who would suspect me?
Because I, you know, I've
always wanted to be a vampire
or something that was built
and it turned into me.
And, you know, because
it's my favorite genre
and it's a genre I've not
ever been able to play in.
- Do you see it like a Guillermo
del Toro type of movie?
- [Whoopi] Listen, if only.
- Right.
- Please, please.
- Okay, so, the last time you were here,
we both were single.
You weren't dating.
Are you dating now?
- No.
- I am.
- Good.
(audience applauding)
Good.
- 'Cause it had been so many years.
I started to get a little worried.
- Well, you know, when
it's meant to happen...
- [Drew] I got too good at being alone.
- Well, no, no. You know what?
Being alone is not a bad thing.
- I love it too much.
(audience laughing)
- Well, perhaps,
if you are not knitting it
together with other stuff,
you can be alone and then not alone.
And then alone.
And then not alone.
- So you could compartmentalize
it a little bit.
- Hit and run.
So maybe a hit and run
is a better way to go.
(Drew laughing)
(audience applauding)
For now.
Until you're, until you
say to yourself, you know,
now I really want someone
to just be part of this.
Right now, that may not be
what you're looking for,
which is probably why you're doing fine.
- So you don't ever get like itchy
to include somebody in the picture?
- For good? No.
- [Drew] But a hit and run?
- Hit and runs are great.
(audience laughing)
Because I...
- Do you still hit and run?
- All the time.
(Drew squeals excitedly)
All the time.
(audience applauding)
Now, here's what's gonna happen.
Now that I've said this to
you, that's all I'm gonna see.
(Drew laughing)
Who is the hit and run?
People are gonna try to figure it out.
You can't.
You can't figure it out.
Because I made it a point to
make sure that that was mine.
I didn't wanna share it.
You know, I don't want it
to be part of other people's
humor stories about me.
- Yep.
- Hit and run.
(Drew laughing)
- I almost did a spit take.
- I know you did.
(upbeat music)